all right Shark Week is here and to
celebrate Cabo Wabo Cantina is offering
a special Shark Tank cocktail this week
only here to tell us more about this
fantastic drink is Leslie Martinez from
Cabo Wabo thank you for joining us hi
thank you for having me here well this
thing by the way looks absolutely
amazing who came up with this uh this
concoction of a cocktail well we've been
serving this cocktail for the past four
years at Cabo Wabble Cantina and it's
been a hit ever since I can tell just it
just it looks fun you know having on
your table what goes inside this thing
we put um absolute lime vodka why do we
make it as you're telling me what goes
inside it so this is the finished
product and you can describe as you go
along and I love it too because there's
all kinds of candies and stuff in it go
ahead so what's the first thing we put
in this thing so we go ahead and put
absolute lime vodka that's the first one
and now how many people I mean if you
drink this by yourself it's going to be
it's gonna be a fun night you can
definitely share it with your buddies I
would say probably about like three
people could share this we put blue
Carousel in here so we got the vodka in
there now we're kind of giving it the
ocean feel open the ocean Vibe we're
putting the ocean water in there and is
there alcohol in this there is it's
absolute vodka Okay now what's the blue
stuff is just flavoring it's liqueur
okay all right what's the third item
we're putting in and we put mojito mix
more in here yes
very strong drink does it come with
straws you just kind of pass it around
the table hold it and pass it around to
your friends as you drink it that would
be very um excessive um we do carry
straws okay they go in here and what's
this sweet and sour all right what's
that for just for fun it's the juice
yeah all right I love your pork you're
not counting you're just
celebrating Shark Week what else goes
into this drink ginger ale
he said three people for this right yeah
about like three four people could drink
this yeah maybe five six three
this is so good and you I see you have
the candy sharks that go in there the
little dummies they throw some gummies
inside to add some fun into it perfect
and then we have a cherry bomb
um what is the Cherry Bomb Trinity and
vodka and that's a whole separate shot
yes so we have this big drink right here
and then you're getting a shot at it
into it okay it's very strong and you do
this you do the shot out of the shark
yes you can either drink it directly
from the mouth or you can go ahead and
pour it in
that's the blood coming out of the shark
exactly okay now as you what is that now
okay she's putting the vodka in there
and then you put it inside there oh that
looks so good that looks delicious now
you also looks delicious and smells so
good is the food that you have here
let's touch on the food because I think
if you have a drink this size you
definitely need to get some food from
Cabo Wabo and your food is fantastic
what do you guys have here so we have a
burrito right over here enchilada style
and we have our Sami Hagar tequila
shrimp it's really good it's one of my
favorite dishes at Cabo Wabo we have
chips and salsa in our taquitos as our
appetizer and the Sammy Hagar connection
if people don't know what's the Sammy
Hagar connection I'm sorry the Sammy
Hagar connection to Cabo Wabo you serve
as as tequila oh yeah Cabo wobble
tequila yes because people like why is
the same Arc connectors Sammy Hagar and
Cobble while we're combined together uh
how much does something like this cost
about 29 and did you get to keep the
sharks that come with it definitely yes
do you keep the glass you do yeah so you
got you know that's worth it 29 for five
six of your friends celebrate shark week
and you get to take this home as a
souvenir you might wake up the next
morning go what did I do when you see
this glass empty and you go oh I know
what I did I was like Cabo wobble last
night Leslie thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it thank you of
course you guys are down there on this
trip right yes right on Las Vegas
Boulevard Planet Hollywood thank you for
joining us we need to get five people to
drink this thing Las Vegas now we will
be right back